people like them I just want to say you
know can we can we all get along can we
can we get along and of course was
Rodney King appealing for calm as the
Los Angeles Riots raged in the spring of
1992
violence swept the city 25 years ago
today after four white police officers
accused of beating King were acquitted
more than 50 people were killed and more
than a billion dollars worth of property
was damaged or destroyed now a quarter
of a century later media via rial shows
us how the violence transformed the city
and the people who lived through it oh
look at that terrible and there's no
police presence down here this was the
first sign 25 years ago that Los Angeles
was in for a very long night did people
angry they have every right to be
politicians misjudged the anger and
police were accused of standing by and
letting it happen and while the city was
on fire kjh radio was in the middle of
it you could feel the heat from the
buildings by us burning for four days
DJ's Andre Russell and lon McHugh stayed
on air broadcasting every brutal moment
I'm not the only one who feels helpless
we need to get ourselves together as a
community you're seeing buildings being
burned down and you're seeing people
running for their lives in the streets
the predominantly black south-central
part of Los Angeles was neglected
plagued with unemployment poverty and
suffering through the crack epidemic do
you feel like what happened in 1992 had
to happen almost in order for there to
be change it was almost like a volcano
absolutely I felt like it had been
rumblings you know it was it was almost
inevitable National Guard troops rolled
into town to help restore order
Karen Lane was 12 years old when the
riots broke out now a lawyer with
Community Coalition Lane has committed
to working on the issues that ignited
the 92 riots like racism and poverty but
rose from the ashes of 1992 were really
people driven community driven solutions
and calling for more accountability
murder rates have plummeted in South LA
LAPD recorded over a thousand homicides
in 1992 but there were just under 300 in
2016
construction of a new NFL stadium and
concert venue in Inglewood have brought
jobs and increased real estate prices so
we have to start to think creatively out
the box of how do we have development
without displacement and how do we
involve the community in doing that
Akeelah Sharia is doing exactly that I
grew up right around the corner in the
joint down housing projects once a
member of the infamous LA gang the Crips
he has reinvested his time and money
back into watts by opening local
a restaurant with celebrity chef Roy
Choi hired 40 people liveable wage job
80% of our staff walk to work
so the 25th anniversary is about a
recommitment you know and a reinvestment
also though in our post 25 years later
many people in South Los Angeles can see
past the pain and view the riots as an
uprising that ignited change for CBS
this morning Saturday midday ovule Los
Angeles that's a I mean I remember the
LA riots and I mean to see how much la
has changed and neighborhoods have
changed Roy Choi is doing great work in
Los Angeles it's great that people are
taking them leadership roles in China I
can't believe it's been 25 years yeah
well yeah